antoine claireaux notre correspondant en
russie s'est rendu à saint pétersbourg
sur les traces d'une entreprise où ça or
faire unique qui pourrait bien
participer à faire renaître l'horloge de
notre dame de paris disparu dans le
dramatique incendie d'avril 2010 9 quel
est le lien entre l' incendie de la
cathédrale notre dame de paris du 15
avril 2019 et cette manufacture de
montres de saint pétersbourg a priori
aucun et pourtant des experts en
horlogerie de cette entreprise étudie
actuellement les documents de l'horloge
disparus afin de déterminer quelle pièce
ils seront en capacité de reproduire la
tragédie qui est arrivé à ce monument
architectural exceptionnel la cathédrale
notre dame de paris a engendré la
douleur dans nos coeurs
[Musique]
nous ne savions pas de quelle manière
nous pouvons aider à restaurer au moins
certains éléments de l'horloge qui a été
touché par l'incendié et était presque
détruite
nous leur avons envoyé notre proposition
en disant que nous étions prêts à
participer autant que possible à leur
restauration
à mesure que les détails seront précisés
nous pourrons probablement commencer le
travail sur certains éléments qu'il sera
possible de fabriquer à l'aide de nos
machines outils et que nous sommes en
mesure de produire il faut dire que
cette manufacture qui remonte à l'époque
soviétique a le savoir-faire aux montres
et horloges de toutes tailles à son
actif
l'horloge monumentale du grand magasin
de jouets moscovite diète qui mirent 4
tonnes emmi six mètres sur 7 plus de
5000 pièces en acier en aluminium et en
titane pour certaines recouvertes d'or
et concernant notre dame
la tâche est tout aussi immense
actuellement nous examinons le modèle
envoyées par nos collègues français nous
évaluions ses caractéristiques nous le
comparons avec les capacités de notre
manufacture
nous procédons à une estimation de la
possibilité de fabriquer les pièces
nécessaires
il s'agit d'un travail considérable à
d'un nombre important de pièces
d'après certaines estimations elles sont
environ 2000
le modèle que nous avons reçues n'est
pas complet il y a des éléments qu'on
peut qualifier ou ne pas qualifier le
pièces comme des goupilles davis des
boulons
au total le nombre est assez important
le projet n'en est qu'à ses débuts
piloté par une association en france qui
cherche avant tout à étudier la
faisabilité de reproduire cette horloge
à l'identique
quoi qu'il en soit notre dame
montée sur cette manufacture
pétersbourgeoise pour mettre sa pierre à
l'édifice et ressuscité son horloge